[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsay show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host open phones this hour
as we talk about your life and your
money
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five
two two five it's a free call and some
say the advice is worth exactly what you
pay for it
robin is in cleveland ohio hey robin how
are you
i'm doing all right how are you today
better than i deserve what's up
i have a question my husband and i are
finishing up
baby step three we have about five
months in savings
and we're debating on whether we should
refinance our home
we have a hundred thousand dollars on
our house and we have around sixty
thousand dollars on
a second mortgage when we were doing
dave ramsey-ish and my husband built a
barn
that he uses as like a side business but
so we were wondering if we should
refinance and
can combine the barn and the house on
the same
payment plan yeah what's the interest
rate on your first mortgage
our interest rate on the first mortgage
is like a 3.7
and on the barn it's like a 6.2 yeah
and you're going to stay in the home a
while oh yeah i don't
we don't plan on ever leaving definitely
definitely refinance it while you're at
it put it on 15-year
you can get cheaper on the barn and
cheaper on the house and so you got 160
000
half 60 000 which you're going to save
three and some change
and you're probably gonna save about
three quarters of a percent on the
hundred thousand on the first
and my husband's concern he says he
feels like he's starting over
i don't know how to help him through
that i don't feel like it's starting
over
because we've already been paying on the
house for 10 years yeah there's a
some people don't um he's one of them
they have the idea that you pay all the
interest up front
and that he has to start overpaying all
the interest and that's because when you
look at an amortization schedule when
you look at your payment schedule
and how much of it is going to interest
out of the very first payment it's
almost all interest
and that makes you think you're
pre-paying interest upfront
sometimes you're not he's not starting
over
so the way the interest is calculated on
a traditional
conventional mortgages it's based on the
outstanding balance
that month and so your very first
payment you have the largest
outstanding balance you will ever have
and so you have the more so a higher
percentage you know 99
of that first payment goes to interest
right
you've seen that you've seen that math
schedule right yeah oh yeah okay
so the what let's just pretend uh let's
pretend it was three percent
which would be .25 a month
a quarter of a percent a month would be
three percent a year
okay so whatever's outstanding that
month
a quarter of a percent is going to be
owed on it
if you're if your interest rate's three
percent and so he's not starting over
he's got a hundred and sixty thousand
dollars and a quarter of a percent
of that will go to a quarter of a
percent will be his
portion of the payment and the rest of
it will be principal which will be a
tiny tiny bit
but you're not starting over you do
mortgages are not
front loaded with interest okay
that's what his he misunderstood that
yeah that's what he's getting hung up on
he doesn't want to start over they're
not free
he's not starting over well he's not
starting over he's starting exactly the
same place he is but with a lower
interest rate
because this month he's going to get
charged one-twelfth of
six percent and some change which is a
half a percent on the sixty thousand
this month he's going to get charged one
twelfth of three point seven percent on
the hundred thousand
and the rest of it is going to go to
principle
it's simple interest calculation the
outstanding balance times the interest
rate
is the amount of interest charged to
that month there is
not a front load on a mortgage
it's only charged for what you have
outstanding so you're not starting over
do a 15-year fixed
and refinance this puppy you need to do
it tj is in new york city hi tj welcome
to the ramsey show
how's it going better than i deserve
what's up
uh so i'm 22 i just graduated in
december of 2021
um i got my job during corona i'm out of
student debt
and i want to leave but um the job and
i'm still living with my parents but the
thing is
since i just since i just turned debt
free i have a thousand dollars
for emergency fund i don't know if it's
okay to leave or should i wait longer
leave what your parents are the job both
will you have another job lined up uh i
have offers coming in
um and i i have a lot of interviews all
the time it's just
when i do the numbers in my head if i
move out i won't be making as much money
as if i look at home in terms of how
much i can take in because obviously
if i live at home i'd also worry about
rent well anybody that has free rent has
more money no duh
right but at some point that doesn't
work like when you're 50 years old that
don't call me and say you won't live
with mom
because it's free right so you want to
get out on your own and start your adult
life that's a normal process young man
i'm proud of you do that yes
okay um i was just wondering if um but
can you afford it i mean are you gonna
how much you're gonna be making at the
new gig
so right now my average would be around
fifty thousand
okay and where are you going to be
living doing that
what city i uh i've
been interviewing in places in new york
um
plays in connecticut and plays in boston
so i i know that's another question to
you is it okay to move far away
from uh you know like from the pair like
from your parents or
whatever the case may be like you
because i might not know anyone in a new
city
uh well it's certainly not against the
law
um yeah it's a matter emotionally it's a
matter emotionally and relationally what
you want to do
right i'm kind of a homebody
if i'm gone very long i i miss my wife
and my family and my kids and my
so i like to get back home i'm not
somebody that likes to be far away
other people i want to be far far away
uh there's nothing
wrong it's just a matter of what how you
want to live what what kind of a life do
you want to create for yourself
um but the three areas that you
described are not far from new york city
at all your parents are obviously in new
york city so
um you know but all three areas you
described are very expensive areas to
live in and you're talking about only 60
000
income which is great coming out of
school that's not a bad income but it is
not living in manhattan income
yeah and like i realized that when i
started looking for new jobs that when i
when that happened
i'm going to be making like nothing in
terms of savings
it's just going to all be going to rent
or food or whatever the case may be yeah
you need to lay out a written
budget not in your head and develop a
game plan that the
that you can live on what you're going
to be making
in a certain area okay and so if i take
this job
in boston i can get a apartment for this
i can
pay my utilities i can buy food and this
will be my income and you need to
project all of that out so that you're
not
you know launching yourself into
[Music]
a problem but you should be able to pull
this off
and yes you should do this this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
do
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
imagine what you could do if you had
control of your most powerful wealth
building tool
your income what if it wasn't all going
to car
payments and to credit card payments and
to sally may
how much different would your life look
like if you had no payments your life
would be incredible it doesn't have to
take as long as you think it's going to
take to get there
it all starts with financial peace
university the class that's helped
nearly 6 million people learn the proven
plan to get out of debt
and build wealth but it's not enough to
just learn the plan you got to put it
into action
every day and the way you do that is by
budgeting
with every dollar you get
every dollar and financial peace
university and a bunch of other things
only at ramsey plus with a ramsey plus
membership
see you can create the life where your
money works for you not against you
wouldn't it be nice to have control of
this subject yeah
get out of debt fast and for good start
your free trial of ramsay plus text
trial
to 33 789 text
trial two three three seven
eight nine i'm dave ramsey your host
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
two john in sunnyvale california welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave how are you doing better than i
deserve man what's up
good uh i just proposed and got engaged
this past saturday
to my fiance congratulations
when's the wedding uh i think we want to
schedule for three months
so basically either the beginning of
october or the very end of september
love it cool good for you getting the
move on
yeah we're going to be sprinting for the
next several weeks
um okay so my question is um
so she has student loan debt 60k i have
student loan debt
34k and then i have another
personal loan from a friend for 15 000.
my fiancee currently has 16
000. we'll we'll come up with some more
money over the next few months to fund
the wedding we'll probably
try to keep that like five thousand but
i'm wondering should she
just throw that towards her student loan
debt and bring in less
into the marriage or can we hang on to
it so we can just completely wipe out my
15
000 personal loans what do you think
doesn't matter they both gotta go
yeah and so you know you're gonna throw
it at one or the other
within the next three months and it's
not going to change the outcome very
much whichever direction you go
um yeah it's probably emotionally
cleaner for her to throw her money
at her debt uh because one of the things
when you get married
is is it's emotionally uh
i mean let's pretend that you were
deeply in debt and she had no debt and a
big pile of money
and then you get married and she pays
off all your debt because we've joined
accounts and joined our lives the way we
should have that
always feels weird when you're doing it
you know what i'm saying
right i do yeah yeah you need to do it
it's the right thing to do to learn to
combine your lives
but it's a normal thing for that to feel
weird and so for her to
reach over with money she had and put it
on what was your debt
now is our debt feels a little weirder
probably than just chunking it onto hers
it really doesn't matter though what's
your health what's your income what's
her income
uh i think he's in the 50 000 range and
i'm at 65.
okay so i'm 120 000 income give or take
115 000 income and um
so you know you just look at that and
say
how quickly are we going to knock this
whole thing out probably within
18 months a year two years somewhere in
there you should be 100
debt free and so it's not going to
matter which way you go
um there's not a i probably would go
ahead and both of you start
once you've got your wedding budget set
aside both of you just start with your
own plans and then combine them in
october
after the marriage and uh hold on i'm
going to send you a copy of the total
money makeover to guide you through that
and that'll be our wedding gift to you
guys and congratulations
hannah is with us in indianapolis hi
hannah how are you
i'm great dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so my main question is whether or not
i should be planning to purchase a home
in the next
two to three years i am 22 just
graduated from
undergrad i have a pretty sizable
savings from working throughout college
um and i just started a graduate program
that is about eight to ten years um
to ten years yeah yep
what are you doing having an elephant
what in the world what takes eight to
ten years to do
i'm getting an md and a phd
why does that take eight to ten years
because i have to do both of them and
both of them are four years
why do you have to do both of them
i want to go into medical research
so a phd will do that
yeah but there's a very big shortage of
physician scientists and
then ih talks about this sometimes phds
don't always have the medical knowledge
to examine things from
that certain perspective yeah that makes
sense
wow what an investment i know
i know of time much less money yeah i
mean you got a decade of your life going
into this
is there any way you can do one and then
work on the other as adult education and
uh i'm that's just that's amazing i'm
amazed at your commitment that's that's
a that's very impressive
okay so you have the money to pay you're
going to be in one location for both of
these
yes yeah the money pay for this
all this tuition so um that's kind of
the reason i'm doing this program the
tuition is fully covered and i get a
training md phd program
now i see what you're doing you got a
fellowship oh okay
yeah oh wow you are you are a rock star
that's amazing good for you thank you
okay um i can breathe better now but
it's still eight years
um uh um
you're gonna and you're gonna so you're
gonna be in one location the whole time
yeah i'd buy a house
yes okay yeah inexpensive i wouldn't go
big dog here because i don't want it
getting in the way of this education
right should i be looking into a condo
yeah something where you don't have to
screw with the maintenance and
i just don't want the real estate to be
a distraction to this
incredibly long and difficult goal that
you have but i think you can do it
okay makes sense yeah you got it you got
a big commitment you've made here to
yourself
and i don't want anything getting in the
way of that because this is an
incredible opportunity for you
wow you're something else i'm impressed
that's amazing way to go hannah
uh wow so this is the way that a you can
get become a medical doctor by the way
uh
and they they you become an employee of
the university is essentially what the
md phd program is for those of you
listening
and um it's very very tough to get
there's just a handful of them around
the nation that you can get each year
but you become an employee of the
university and so what she's going to be
doing while she's
doing this during eight years also she's
gonna be teaching uh at the university
in different you know undergrad classes
and so forth as a prof
and uh in return they as an employee
in a sense you get your md phd
uh program and um
yeah so she's getting several hundreds
of thousands of dollars of education
there free
it's uh it's a pretty amazing thing
she's pulled off so
kate for those of you don't know why i'm
a guest number one eight years is
freaking incredible but number two
it's probably a four or five hundred
thousand dollar ticket she just got
that's pretty neat and she's obviously
brilliant uh you don't get to do this
unless you really smart
that's how it works so i don't qualify
and so i'm impressed
it's pretty impressive very cool open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five brenda says in
michigan
can i buy life insurance on my
ex-husband no
i received 400 a month from his social
security if he passed away i would lose
that
whoopee it's 4 800 a year go grow
yourself a life he's your ex
move on with your life if you're
dependent on 400
a month you need to work on other stuff
no you don't need to buy life insurance
can you yeah you don't really have an
insurable interest
you'd have to have his permission and it
wouldn't be much of a policy anyway to
only cover five thousand dollars a year
you could check with xander insurance if
you want to and you might be able to
would i no he's called the ex-husband
for a reason x move on this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
question from the lobby here at ramsey
solutions kevin is with us hey kevin how
are you
hey dale i'm great good uh uh so my
question today i'm from california i'm
here
visiting my brother who works at ramsey
solutions oh fun um
and i have a super silicon valley
question uh
i'm uh engineering manager at a major
tech company
and you know my my salary is well in
excess of of six figures
but that's it's pretty much at least for
the last like few tax years
been exactly half regular salary
and exactly half company stock and so
then
it's like very repeatable company stock
investments that are
like gonna last for three or four years
and i i wanted to ask this question
because it's super common
uh compensation package for engineers
in silicon valley for sure yeah and so
the question is you know if you say not
me but if
somebody was like you know i'm making
400 000 a year
and it's in half and salary and half in
stock it isn't obviously guaranteed
to remain consistent um like
how should i win like in the crazy
housing market there
what kind of income should i be thinking
about in terms of the mortgage i can
afford
and then maybe just your thought on like
how you would treat that type of income
if you were managing it
and trying to count on a certain salary
right well if you're going to live in
silicon valley you're going to be making
if you're going to buy a home you're
going to be making 400 000. otherwise
you're not going to buy you're not going
to be living there you'll be commuting
in
okay because it's that's probably one of
the most expensive pieces of real estate
in the nation right now
manhattan silicon valley that's two big
dogs right there
so uh uh you know you're going to count
that income
in your equation when you buy a house
you're going to say i make 400 000
a year or whatever it is you make okay
and uh so you're gonna count that now
what that means is
this stock that you're receiving
typically is not restricted in this case
right
it's you get it in like four-year chunks
and it it vests every six months okay so
it is restricted it's restricted in it
but it kind of like starts to vest in
like a steady flow
right but is it four years before that
particular
chunk is released it's it's it fully
releases
over the four year term six months at a
time oh
and that's a very common uh investment
strat strategy from some of the
companies
well it depends on where they are in
their maturity
with their stock and so forth but yeah
okay uh
you don't have access to it so we can't
count it
uh if you can't liquidate it you can't
use it to pay a bill yeah
okay it's that simple so you can only
count what you've got access to
now once you've gotten far enough into
this four years into this then you're
going to have it
that much releasing regularly because it
will have built up
uh so if you're four years in then you
count the whole thing but you count
what's releasing
yeah what you've got access to make
sense for you for your calculation
uh so that answers the question on what
you do for housing a housing budget and
so forth
then the other issue is how much of this
stock do you want to end up owning
i'm sure it's a wonderful company and
i'm sure the stock is wonderful
do you really want all of your net worth
because you're going to have millions of
dollars of this stuff
tied up in a single stock my answer is
no
i don't i don't care who it is i mean
probably the best stock out there would
probably be apple right as an example
and uh it's a gold standard it's an
incredible company
flushing cash but they haven't always
been
and anybody can make mistakes just ask
steve jobs and so
uh you know the uh uh i i'm not gonna
have all of my wealth in
a single stock that would scare the p
wadden out of me
so i'm gonna begin to liquidate it and
move it into other
things over time i recommend that
regardless of how you're getting a
single stock that you don't end up with
more than 10 of your net worth in it
so i'm going to systematically be
liquidating it
you're taxed on it anyway uh because
it's compensation
as you're receiving it so uh you go
ahead and liquidate it and
uh you know and again as it's not to say
that the company is not a good company
i don't care who it is how stable they
are how big they are
what their track record is i'm not
having all of my
wealth in one single stock that's just
playing russian roulette and i'm not
gonna do it so um
i'm gonna systematically roll out of it
and i'm going to count what's released
what i've got access to
as my income for the calculation of
getting your mortgage
congratulations sounds like you got a
fun gig man thank you very cool thanks
for stopping by thanks steve
this is the dave ramsey show bradley is
oh it's not it's the ramsay show i'm
sorry bradley's in atlanta georgia today
it's the dave ramsey show yeah
whatever what's up bradley hey dave how
you doing
better than i deserve man how can i help
so
i got a question my wife and i have paid
off
about 60 000 since december um
so and we're through our emergency fund
and looking over the 401 k so i have a
roth
and a pre-tax traditional
and i just want to see if i can get some
clarification um i know we you i always
hear you say you want to keep the
government's hands off the government's
hands off of it
and so i just want some clarification
between the two
well the roth grows tax-free the pre-tax
you don't pay taxes on the amount you
put in until you pull it out years and
years and years later
and you're gonna pay taxes on the whole
stinking thing so let's say you steadily
invest
for a number of years and you have a
million dollars in your 401k
if it's a traditional 100 of that
million is taxable
because you haven't paid taxes on what
you put in yet and you haven't paid
taxes on the growth yet and it's all
taxable
so taxes on a million dollars let's say
is 300 grand
okay right if it's a roth
and you have a million dollars a hundred
percent of it is yours
so it's a three hundred thousand dollar
swing on this answer per million that
you and that you end up with
uh so if you end up with a couple
million dollars it's a six hundred
thousand dollar difference
so you do the wrong man you do the roth
i see
awesome okay thank you so much dave
thank you for the call
nick is with us nick is in new jersey hi
nick how are you
hi dave how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
so i have a question uh i'm currently
living with my girlfriend and we work at
the same company
but in september i will be starting a
new job which is in a completely
different location
so i'll be driving there so she finds
herself needing a car
so she's looking to buy a new car which
i know is a
big no-no um and i'm just having trouble
kind of convincing her not to do it
she's like in love with the car and i
feel like she's like
setting her whole mind on what he's
doing i don't want to be like mean to
her or like say like hey like you
shouldn't do this
but not like be supportive or anything
so i guess how do i just
walk out listen when you love someone
and they're doing something
stupid you're not supposed to be
supportive
right you should not be supportive don't
be so
wishy-washy i don't want to be
supportive of course you don't want to
be you don't support them doing things
they're going to bring harm to
themselves you love her
so no i'm not going to be supportive of
stupid activities and buying a brand new
car when you're a broke single girl is a
stupid idea
by the way buying a brand new car is a
stupid idea unless you've got at least a
million dollar net worth
because they go down in value so fast
okay how old is she she's 24 and i'm 22.
okay all right here's the thing
if you want to live your life like a
child and say yolo
you only live once i'm gonna get me a
new car okay
then you can do that whether you're 24
whether you're 54
and you're what's called immature
okay if you i don't care what your age
is i'm talking about your emotional
stability your emotional maturity
because you're saying thank god it's
friday oh god it's monday and your
planting windows
about four feet long instead of having a
runway that looks out into the future
and says what is a
wise purchase that a freaking adult will
make
and here's the thing she doesn't make
enough money to lose as much as she's
gonna lose the day she drives that car
off the lot
you know when you drive that car over
the curb and it goes boom boom
that's ten thousand dollars
so no you buy a two-year-old or older
car this is what millionaires
do they buy used cars and drive used
cars until they're millionaires
and no i'm not going to be supportive of
stupid stuff she's hurting herself
so you want to sit down and kindly
gently go
the math on this doesn't work it's not
the right thing to do
you're not supposed to be supportive
when people are doing dumb things
you're supposed to kindly and firmly be
unsupportive
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thanks for joining us america we're so
glad you are here
lyden is with us in boise idaho is it
leiden is that correct
yes how can i help sir hi dave
really good to talk to you i have two
questions for you
i'm a certified public accountant five
years ago i purchased a practice
from one of the partners in my firm for
about four hundred thousand dollars
in the last five years i've paid off 225
000 that i still owe 175.
the last two years working in taxes has
been
very interesting with all of the
different law changes that we've
experienced
and tax season has been extended
over the last two years and i think
unfortunately i got a small look at what
it's like to not go through
a full tax season a busy season and i
kind of liked it
so i'm thinking about uh
changing my practice perhaps selling it
and i wanted to know what your
recommendations are
how you prepare what steps need to be
taken to make that step
the the second one that i had is what
are your rules regarding the purchase of
goodwill for people like
cpas doctors
lawyers those type of folks i often
consult with them and
i haven't heard a lot on your show
regarding how or if you should purchase
goodwill
yeah i'm uh
i i i'm a utilitarian
on that subject meaning that
the goodwill needs to produce revenue
otherwise it has no value
okay and so if the doctor's name is not
cr is not adding bottom line to his
practice
then his good will is questionable it
needs to create money that or it doesn't
have value
you follow me now there's other people
that would argue against that
that mode of thinking but if i'm buying
something as an investor
uh you know we've been in business 35
years and you know you're buying our
name
well no your name's not worth squat
unless it's making money
that's what makes it worth something and
so that's in a sense goodwill right
and the same is true in cpas the same is
true in law firms the same is true and
other things but uh but but you know
your world is a little different it may
have more value there
than it might other places uh but
truthfully unless you can see your way
to monetize it or it is currently being
monetized
uh it really doesn't have um
it's it's a theory at that point as far
as i'm concerned but again i'm i'm very
utilitarian i'm very practical on the
way i look at that so as far as
preparing your practice i mean
you've been you've probably coached
people on this as much as i have
uh it's a matter of being able to prove
the income
and have reasonable expense lines and uh
reasonable predictable revenue lines
and so if the revenue minus the expenses
creates profit no duh
uh and those are all predictable lines
then i've got a real easy valuation i'm
just going to say okay what kind of rate
of return do i want
uh uh and it's your cap rate right it's
you're going to just multiply it by four
if you want a 25 percent rate of return
on your on your you know
on your net operating income right and
so
if you want 20 rate of return you
multiply it by five i mean it's a
it's a multiple of profits as a rate of
return is a valuation process that i
would use if i'm buying a business
and uh the thing that we all get into
and you've seen this all the time
is these people walking around they go
well you know i don't i don't really
turn in all my
revenue i don't really pay taxes on all
of it well
you know so you say you're willing to
lie to the government and i'm supposed
to believe you on how much this thing's
worth i don't think so i think we're
going to count what you really turn in
dude
and you're not doing that kind of thing
obviously but um
you know what you've got to do is firm
up a
uh a forecastable believable future
for a buyer does that make sense yes
and i think the more the more you can
print that picture
and i you know your your buyer is is
god help you a cpa right and so they're
going to be a conservative
buyer by their nature and a detailed or
a detail-oriented person
so there's not going to be a lot of
bravado or grandiosity around this it's
just going to be in the numbers
i bet because that's how you would do it
right probably how you did it when you
bought it yeah
yes it was and i i don't i think that
there are other ways of
i've i've seen other ways of selling
practices i've i've looked to buying
other people out
after i purchased my first practice
locals and
others in in bigger cities trying to
expand
so i have seen other ways of doing it oh
there's plenty of other ways
i'm just saying you you this is just the
method i would use um
but yeah there's a lot of ways i mean
you can do multiples of gross
and a business is standardized as yours
you can just take a top line into a
multiple
radio business does that a lot they'll
take you they'll take cash flow
and do a multiple of cash flow instead
of running it on straight net
profit but um but the only formula
i mean i again i'm just
i'm a simple guy if i put in a hundred
thousand bucks
and i want a twenty percent rate of
return on that that's twenty thousand
dollars i wanna see that come back
you know i wanna see that how that works
i want a five year payout a five year
break even period on this investment
and that's how i'm gonna approach it if
i were doing the deal
so i think you i think you know enough
to
more than enough to pull this off and do
it beautifully and i'm congratulations
by the way
jerry is with us in new york city jerry
is
hi how are you jerry hey mr ramsay
how's everything better than i deserve
basically
good good good basically i lived in new
york city i brought uh
in jersey not too far over the bridge
for location because i work here
uh the lights uh as a license uh
pressure vessel inspector
and basically i brought there and i did
i have i'm a disabled vet so i basically
get a tax break of 100 offer
off a residency um i bought a
multi-family
and and i have to live there so i have
to
i want to rent out the other unit which
is a five over three it's a three
bedroom i'm renting i'll stay in the
five-bedroom unit with
uh 13 square square hundred feet uh foot
basement and i just wanted to make sure
i made the right decision because i
i don't know it's it's still in a flood
zone that's a problem
and it's always dwelling on me that i
purchased this and
i don't know if it's a big deal or not
well how much of a flood zone is it i
mean you think you're going to get
flooded or is that just a technicality
um the last one the last one was in 2012
with uh that that storm yeah and how
long was it before that before the other
one
nothing dated that i looked at i haven't
only been one
on record yes right well i don't think
i'm worrying about that
there's a river that runs by it's not
too far it's about maybe about
500 yards away there's commercial units
there
yeah um yeah i mean i'm not too worried
about it because
i'm prepared to to you know defend my
house well you bought flood insurance
too
right absolutely yeah absolutely i got
it i got elevation certificate to make
sure that the insurance goes down
i'm not worried about it right
one flood in the history of the property
ever
and it was a a freak event in 2012. i'm
fine with that i'm not i'm not worried
about that
right right and then just the tolls and
everything going back but you know what
it is my job covers that
but they may have you know they
geographically it's in the area
um just that's pretty much it right
there mr ramsay it was
so you're worried about the flood and
the tolls but the tolls are paid for so
you're not worried about those
yeah yeah that's pretty much it's a real
problem man
you know i waited you know i just came
out of the navy i did my 20 years and i
was
i always wanted to get a house and i
finally did it and and
it was the flood zone thing my realtor
which is very close to me
uh sh you know she said listen you know
this is an investment for you you know
anything and
then live there three years and move
absolutely you'll make some money on it
and you will have a good experience
um i i i have a 1300 square foot
basement which i love but i can't really
draw you can't dwell on that town
exactly yeah you're fine you did good
hey thank you for your service by the
way
appreciate you man that puts us hour of
the ramsey show
in the books kelly daniel is our
associate director and phone screener
social producer and phone screener ben
is filling in for james childs today i'm
dave ramsey your host
and we'll be back
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five sarah starts off this
hour in seattle hi sarah how are you
i'm fantastic how are you doing today
better than i deserve what's up in your
world
hey so um unfortunately my marriage
didn't work out the way
i had planned and as part of the door's
decree i have to pay my ex about 75 000
out of our uh house so i was
i've been kind of looking at um interest
rates and where they've been going
and when i look at them i see that i can
get a lower interest rate
but higher origination fees so my
overall mortgage would be lower
or i can get a higher interest rate and
lower origination fees so my overall
mortgage payment would be
higher and i was just wondering which in
the long run would be the better
decision i suspect i know but i just
want to get your opinion
now points you're talking about paying
points to buy
down the rate effectively one point
is one percent of your loan balance
one point will generally buy down your
rate about an
eighth of a percent okay
okay translation eight years to break
even
okay if it drops your interest rate one
eighth of one percent it takes you and
it costs you one percent then it takes
you eight years to get that money back
if you don't keep the mortgage eight
years
uh you will not you will lose money on
having prepaid your interest with points
the average mortgage in america lasts
5.6 years
because people refinance or sell or
whatever
and so i would not pay points i would go
with the higher interest rate
and the less up front because you're in
a life transition stage
and you may not be in that house five
years from now matter of fact there's a
high probability you won't be
all right so because i live in such an
excellent area
it i don't know that i could afford i
was very fortunate and i bought the
house
in 2009 excuse me in 2009 so
it's more than doubled its value since
then and i could not buy into my
neighborhood now
um so i i don't know that i could
sell the house um and
make be able to buy something comparable
today
that's not what my point is
in five years i don't know what your
life's gonna look like you could be
making six times what you make now
god willing well you could just i mean
you could discover uh fire i don't know
i don't know what you're gonna do in
seattle you could do all kinds of
magical things in seattle right
um oh yeah for sure you know and so i i
don't know i mean i think your future is
bright
so you've gone through hell recently no
question about that but we're not going
to project that as your future
yeah and what you said although it was
different logic is what i was thinking
and my thought was the difference in the
monthly mortgage how long would it take
me to make up the origination fees
eight years which yeah on average now so
you can do the math
and and say okay every if i
if i pay this many extra percentage
points what does it lower it and you
just divide it out you can tell
exactly what it's doing but typically
it's around an eighth
of a percent point one two five it would
take me about
87 months to make up today yeah and it
just doesn't make sense
yeah in my head it didn't but then i was
thinking about
how long i would have we don't know
we don't know exactly and so it's not
it's not worth the gamble
if the break even was two years we'd go
with it
but the break even is not gonna be two
years and so we're not gonna go so
you're looking for what we call a par
quote zero origination
zero points yes okay power quote i will
remember
yeah and talk to churchill mortgage if
you want a good one because that's the
company we've endorsed for 25 years here
and they do a great job and they can
definitely take care of you there
i'm sorry you're going through this
kiddo but the future is bright it's uh
gonna get better
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five amanda is in canada hi amanda how
are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i was just calling um my husband and i
are technically on baby step
three but i will confess i have been
cheating your system we still have our
credit card and we do not do a monthly
budget
um i've been on step three since march
2020 because we've had to buy two cars
which we paid for with cash
and um we had a baby so we had all the
expenses of that too oh and there was
this little coveted thing that happened
yeah
okay not a bad not a bad year no it was
quite the year
um but i am now at the point where
we get to the end of each month and i
have no idea where all their money went
and i'm just sick and tired of it
because we want to be saving to
have our emergency fund and do a down
payment on a house because we're
currently renting
good um but the thought of budgeting
really freaks me out my husband is in
construction so his
income isn't necessarily always for sure
each month
and so i'm not sure what freaks you out
it just all be different uh
what if that could come up in a month or
like if my husband
worked overtime we get more money or if
you stick a day we lose money and then
how do you
put that in a budget when you you don't
know what's going to happen okay so you
need a process and a system
to handle the ups and downs in the
irregular part of your world
the unpredictable part of your world in
order to not be freaked out right
is that what you're telling me yeah yeah
is there something else freaking you out
about the budget
i just i i love planning everything i
like knowing everything in advance and
um and you're not going to be able to
yes
okay so here's how you do it okay what
portion of his income
like out of the last uh how long has he
been doing construction
he's in year four of his apprenticeship
okay let's just say
three year for the last three years what
was his worst
month of income
[Music]
just pick a rough number two grand
two grand what's his best uh
about five grand okay so that's our
range of irregular income
and are you working outside the home as
well
i'm currently on maternity leave until
next may
okay and with that i get about thirteen
hundred dollars a month
okay so we have thirteen hundred and two
thousand that we count on right
right okay and so you do a budget on
3300
okay and uh if you want to do a little
bit more because you're probably going
to count on a little more than 2 000 out
of him right
so you you pick the number you can count
on that's what my point is
and you run a budget on that meaning you
put that at the top of the page
on your every dollar budget and you give
every dollar
a name and then you make a list of
things you want to do
or need to do that didn't make the cut
and you prioritize that list if i get a
dollar more than 3 300 what am i gonna
do
i'm gonna put it on number one once
number one's done i'm gonna put it on
number two
number three number four number five
number six number seven so you have a
prioritized spending plan on
items that didn't make the 3 300
budget and now you have a system
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 a month
by switching
to pure top just go to feartalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
so when my wife and i were dating 40
years ago
i was driving a monte carlo
with the second engine and the third
transmission in it
and i had done all of the changes each
time i stripped through one of those
and the old car had it was just gone i
mean it had 250 000 miles on it i had
worn it out three times over
and we're driving along i had a dollar
16 in my checking account
and we're driving along on our second
date and i was explaining to her how
someday i was going to be a millionaire
and we went across a railroad track the
muffler fell off my car
[Laughter]
this is a true story oh and here's how
stupid it was okay
i actually had a toolbox in the trunk
because i'm used to working on a car all
the time because it was always falling
apart
and uh two towels because the muffler
had fallen off before one towel to lay
on one to pick the muffler up with and
put it back on and
9 16 put that u clamp back and put the
muffler back in place in the
9 16 craftsman and ratcheted it back up
on there
i don't work on my cars anymore
i lifted the hood on one of them the
other day i don't even know what the
flip is in there
it looks like a computer or something is
in there i don't have any idea
the last time i worked on a car it had a
spark plug not a fuel injector
and i don't i don't even i don't diy my
cars by the way i don't pull my own
teeth either
and i um and i teach investing for a
living and america comes to me to learn
how to handle money and how to invest
and i don't do my own investing i
understand it
but i don't do my own i go to a smart
vester pro
and i talked to my guy that i've used
for 15 years it's my friend
that's a smartvestor pro here in town
and he and i talk about
my mutual funds and we look at other
investments we can do and
i he schools me and i school him back
and forth and then we decide what i'm
gonna do
i have a pro in my corner and some of
you are out there i'm gonna do it myself
well yeah go and pull your own teeth
stupid that's just dumb okay you need a
pro in your corner
you don't do investing d-i-y
do-it-yourself is good for some things
but you know the pandemic taught us that
a whole bunch of you jumped out because
you freaked out
and you jumped out when the market dove
down about
what 12 about 14 months ago now the
market tanked
on pandemic fears and you bought you
you sold at the bottom because you
didn't have somebody in your corner
talking you off the ledge
and we've got all kinds of research that
says that people do do it yourself
investing
screw up all the time don't do it put
somebody in your corner
ramsay solutions.com smart vester
we'll hook you up with one of the
smartvestor pros that we recommend
it'll hook you up with a list of them in
your areas and you can decide what you
who you want to use and how you want to
do it but you're looking for somebody
with a heart of a teacher
and you know don't do it yourself
there's some things i mean it's it's not
that complicated but
i don't do it myself and i know what the
flip i'm doing
i have somebody in my corner smart
fester go to ramseysolutions.com
smart vester derry lynn or daryl lynn
what
what is this one damn i don't know daryl
lynn is in bend oregon
hey darylene how are you good having you
i'm destroying your name what is it
anne daryl anne okay daryl and i'm so
sorry how can i help
no you're fine um i have a quick
question about
a truck loan we just got um my husband
went and bought a
truck for his business um and so my
question
is should we pay off the truck loan with
our
personal finances because we have um
some savings
we're looking at buying a house
eventually um so we have a down payment
savings in the bank right now
and we could pay off the truck in full
but it wouldn't be the business account
paying off the truck right now it would
be the
personal savings account darwin it's a
personal loan he signed for it
personally
it's not a business our business is not
very big
he just justified buying a truck that he
didn't need and
bought himself a dadgum truck did he
pretty brand new yeah yeah yeah he went
but he went and bought him a boy toy and
called it business i'm calling bs
yeah just pay it off it was a stupid
idea and you can't justify it and call
it business because it's not a business
loan bank didn't make the business alone
the bank made you alone
it's personal you're personally liable
on this
yeah we'll use it for the business
because he has a guiding business for
hunting
and so he had to get a truck for that
but um yeah so how much does he make in
his guiding business
around 80 000 this year okay and what'd
the truck cost
35 yeah see i told you it's bs didn't i
there's no way you take an 80 000 gross
revenue business and do a 35 thousand
dollar investment
that you could have done for 5 000 and
he could a 5 000
truck will do a guiding business so the
other 30 that he spent was because he
wanted a truck
that's what this was and this is a
classic small business mistake
by the way everybody does it but yeah
you guys got in my point is i'm not
going to make a big deal about this one
but you guys got to stop that crap
because it's going to make you it's an
excuse to continue to do stupid
and you can't do it so you shouldn't
have bought it bad idea
can't business justify it that's just
true that's just not the truth okay so
anyway pay it off
and uh don't do this kind of stuff again
do not
do this kind of stuff again christina is
with us in dallas
texas hi christina how are you
hi dave thank you for taking my calls
sure what's up
um so i'm getting married in september
and i just wanted your advice
um my fiance has a house and would
prefer if i get
if i move in with him um when we get
married but i would actually prefer to
buy a house together to start out a new
life instead of
moving into his bachelor pad um
in terms of the background he has about
a hundred thousand
worth of debt um that's between student
loans car payments credit cards
i don't have any debt um i'd be coming
with about a hundred and forty thousand
cash um and that's between like cash and
some and most research accounts
and i wanted to use the money for a down
payment on a house
um and if he does sell his then he will
essentially wipe out all his debt
with the equity that he gets from his
house um
and if we do move in if i do move into
his house
there is some different maintenance that
has to happen
and also i would prefer if there was no
renovations done as well to make it more
our house um so i just wanted your
advice as to
what we should do what is also
when you get married if he sells it what
will it will he put in his pocket how
much equities he got
and you would put at least 160 000 in
his pocket
okay so you have three hundred thousand
between you and
he has a hundred and what in debt
about a hundred thousand okay so you're
gonna have two hundred thousand left
over for a down payment right
yes after you're debt free so you sell
his house
and you take a 200 000 down payment and
buy the house together and you're
debt-free
okay so one of the things we were
thinking of doing since the market is so
crazy was
buying a house first and then turning
around and selling him
no just so we're not kind of enough no
no okay no
you go buy a house after you're married
and after his sales
you guys got enough debt without end up
owning two houses
yeah and and in the event where
you have trouble finding a house because
uh well you go rent something for six
months whoop dee dumpty you just got
married
okay but you're not gonna have that much
trouble
just calm down you got 200 000 walking
around in your pocket surely to god you
can find a house in dallas texas to live
in
yeah it's true there's a lot of houses
there's a lot of houses there
yeah that's true yeah just judge get the
hell you know get married
sell his bachelor he can go and sell it
now if he wants move into apartment
he could do that before you get married
i mean he can sell it now and move an
apartment for a few months and then
uh you can join him in the apartment
while you all look for a house that'd be
okay
join him in the apartment after marriage
and then y'all go look for a house
he's got he's out of debt got some money
in his pocket you got your money
put it together we go buy us a house
while we're living in the apartment that
way you got a little patience you have
to freak out
that's all right go and sell it now it
gives you plenty of time
don't get caught with two payments bad
idea
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage michaela is with us hi
michaela how are you
good how are you i am better than i
deserve where do you live
i live in paducah kentucky that's fun
yeah and uh how much have you paid off
33 493 and
something since 87 cents good for you
and your range of income i'm sorry how
long did that take 18 months
good for you and your range of income
during that time about 70 000.
okay what do you do for a living i'm a
labor and delivery nurse
you're a lib a delivery nurse labor
delivery labor and delivery awesome
yeah that's a fun job i love it yeah
good for you that's great
yeah so 33 000 in debt
was what a student loans and a car loan
how much of it was car about 10 000.
it's about 23 in student loans
okay how old are you 23. okay so you
just come out of school and attack
this or tell me the story what happened
yeah um
well we like to say i was living in
stupid when i was in school
my parents saved money and so i could
have paid cash for
college but my lifestyle wasn't really
accepting it so i took out unnecessary
loans
and then it kind of came back to the
lord january 2019
graduated may 2019 and then
moved from texas to kentucky in july
and decided that i didn't want debt and
i didn't want to do it anymore so
just got rid of it came on so you grew
up knowing better
yes and so mom and dad were cheering you
on when she woke up huh oh yeah
so you got the new job pass the bars or
pasture boards got to be a nurse
starting the big girl job all that stuff
and here we go game on yeah
and 18 months later you're done yes good
for you thank you
good for you that's so cool i'm so proud
of you i bet your mom and dad are oh
they're super
proud i'm bad i bet who came along with
you somebody i see somebody in the
peanut gallery over here yes this
is papa he's my grandpa oh wow so he's
super proud then
yeah yeah very good good he gets to
watch his grandbaby be smart that's a
good thing i like that
yeah all right neat very neat so
um how did you connect to us
well my parents made me take financial
peace university
senior year of high school before i
graduated
so i knew about you for a while ignored
it for a long time
but you flunked the class i did i did
great in the class in high school and
then i just
forgot it all i know i'm kidding you
didn't take it with you to college i got
you not at all
all right so you knew what to do yes and
uh you did you go back and review that
stuff or what
yeah mom and dad reviewed it with me a
little bit mom helped me with budgets
all the time because i got really
frustrated a lot
but yeah we just kind of reviewed it and
so they really jumped in and coached you
through this 18 month time oh yeah
and and you accepted that coaching yeah
willingly yes
good for you that's very neat i like
this story
good story so now you're a pro you paid
off 33 000
you've redeemed yourself
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of that is
oh gosh budgeting i use that every
dollar app
and it's like my bible my little
lifeline um
so i use that and i i mean it was really
hard work i worked lots of overtime and
on-call shifts and
anything extra went straight to the debt
so it was hard work but
i mean now it's all my money so
so 18 months tough
was it worth it oh yeah how's it feel
now
oh it's so good i'm i actually have my
full emergency fund
so now i get to invest yeah and
have fun with your story you kind of got
to feel almost like
clean oh yeah yeah like you cleaned up a
dirty spot or something
yeah you know that's i like that good
for you
very good excellent excellent what was
the hardest part of this for you
all the hard hours or what well yeah
um probably the budgeting and the
planning
i'm super like a super planner i'm super
focused but
if anything is kind of off a little bit
like i kept wanting to pay it off faster
and faster and faster
which i did pay it off six months faster
than i thought
so it took mom and dad to kind of be
like no hey you're
you're paying it off you're doing great
you're setting aside money so
yeah i mean you're doing a couple grand
a month here yeah yeah that's that's
pretty substantial
yeah yeah good for you well done well
done yeah
so you're 23 years old 100 debt free
and you have all of that in your rear
view mirror will you ever go back in
debt now oh gosh no
too much trouble no i love it well well
done
very well done we're very proud of you
good job and obviously your family is as
well
so excellent excellent job you're
inspiring thank you
very very good yeah you're not a victim
you decide to take it on head on
good very good very good we got a copy
of the legacy journey for you
that's the next chapter in your story
you've changed your whole legacy
with this knowledge and the maturity
you've used to attack it and
clean up the mess and to move forward
without it that's very very good and a
copy of the total money makeover for you
to give to somebody else and help them
start their journey the whole thing so
very very very good all right michaela
from paducah kentucky
labor and delivery nurse 23 years old
33 000 paid off in 18
months making 70 000 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one i'm debt free
yay
[Applause]
i love it yeah
now that one was for all you moms and
dads that have raised financial peace
babies
and you are worried that they lost their
minds they may lose their minds but they
can go find them
[Laughter]
and michaela did she did a great job of
bringing it back around that's
excellent excellent stuff yeah i
i swear y'all the hardest part of
parenting is when your kids are old
enough to make their own decisions
like they're grown-ups and stuff and you
can't tell them what to do anymore
and you just have to watch them make
their own decisions mine thankfully have
made really good decisions i don't
really have any huge critique of my kids
but
man watching people that you love that
you can't tell them what to do do stupid
stuff
is painful it's just painful and
uh you know and then to see her come
back around that's just a wonderful
story of redemption right there
lots of financial peace babies out there
i've been doing this show a long time so
a lot of these young folk in their 30s
and 20s uh grew up
listening to this old man talk about
getting out of debt and living on a
budget
and living on less than you make and
you know it's weird it it that that
voice just comes back in your head when
you need it it's funny how that works
and
so honored to uh get to you know get to
talk to yet
another generation of this very very
well done
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five tyler's in jonesboro
arkansas hey tyler what's up
hey thanks for taking a call um my
question is in regard to my student
loans
um and i know kind of today this isn't
relevant but
if the cares act is finished
in september like they're saying it is
when student loans start
bringing back the interest rates i was
wondering is it
in my best interest to look at
refinancing my student loans at that
point in time
sure if you can get a lower rate okay
you do you only can do a student loan
refi one time
and so it needs to be a lower rate okay
and that's why i asked now let me ask
you this how much student loan debt do
you have
today i have um forty thousand
what's your household income around 56.
okay so when are you gonna pay this off
well if i keep
in the debt snowball like it's laid out
now
these are spaced out over eight loans so
the student loan
portion of everything would be around 16
months
okay well you're not gonna save a lot by
refinancing but you can refinance it and
cost anything to refinance
but i mean if you save one percent for
16 months on forty thousand dollars it's
not spit
and we're talking about four or five
hundred bucks here okay
so i mean it's not it's not it's okay
but it doesn't change your life what
changes your life is knocking any
stinking things in the head and killing
them
yeah i understand yeah finish the debt
snowball with great intensity is 98
of your issue two percent of your issue
one percent of your issues your interest
rate
because you're not gonna have them for
very long the interest rate doesn't
matter much when you're gonna have it
for a very very short period of time
that's the point so good job man good
job you're paying attention i'm proud of
you
this is the ramsey shack
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsey show open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five diana
is in jackson mississippi hi diana how
are you
i thank you i'm doing fine thank you for
taking my call
i am a recent retiree i retired last
year
and i have at um 4-3 b that was rolled
over into an
ira and right now in the market it's
worth 35
000 i've got debt but at 38
000 not counting my house and i was
thinking about using that 35 000
in the ira to pay that debt off
but i would have to pay taxes on that
money on top of that
that was going to be my baby step number
three
which is that three months you know back
up emergency fund so i'm looking at
i have about almost 6 000 coming in
each month with military retirement
my state teaching retirement and i just
started social security
in april and i was wondering is it wise
to use that ira money to pay that debt
off
is that the only nest egg you have
no i've got an ir i'm an annuity
that won't mature for another four years
and um what is it worth
right now it's at 1900. dollars
oh you're talking about monthly income
and my monthly income is 5 000. no no no
no
when you say 1900 that's the total
balance of the annuity or that's the
income it's going to create
what happened is i had an annuity and i
foolishly let that 7 000 be
taken out and reinvested in another
company's annuity
and i found out that person didn't take
my 7 000 and put in an
annuity he put it in a retirement fund
and took a hundred of it and started a
bank account of a hundred dollars i just
found this out last year
okay so the whole account is only worth
two thousand dollars
right you have any other money that's
your only nest egg is thirty eight
thousand plus that
i have my 1 000 emergency fund
i have the 35 000 in the
ira i've got two uniform gifts to minors
for my granddaughters i won't mess with
them
one's worth i think seven thousand one's
worth
about three thousand um
and then i just have my retirement
military retirement
and so basically you're planning on
living off of the income
stream of the social security your
military retirement
and your uh your pension fund retirement
right because you don't have any money
not really not not to amount to anything
okay all right i'm just trying to make
sure you didn't have a half million
dollars laying over in some account
that's what i was trying to understand
okay so no ma'am i would not cash that
out
no i would not cash that out i would use
the income that you have to pay off your
debt as quickly as you can
and then continue and use the income
that you have and get your home paid off
how much do you own your home
62 000. i just refinanced it from a 5.4
interest rate to 2.5 interest rate
that was a good move okay yup so here's
the thing
you've got the other debt and the 62 000
and you've got a wonderful monthly
income to attack it all with
and you're 63. so over the next four or
five years i want you to pay off all of
it
it should be 100 debt-free before you're
70 okay
i sure will try no you can do it you can
do it it's time for you to concentrate
because you don't need all these
payments hanging around your neck
mortgage or otherwise
going up into your later years and so
you've done you've worked too hard
to to end up broke at the end of this
story so
um thank you for your service by the way
in the military we appreciate you
um aniko is with us aniko
is in bend oregon hi nico how are you
hi um it's annika monica
see i screwed it up i'm sorry i was
trying so hard what's up how can i help
it's okay my joke is i'm either on or
off
[Applause]
okay i've got to tell you you came into
my life when my child was born
17 years ago and i've been a pretty good
kid i'm 51 years old
and i was ready to retire
had no debt had a house and
had left my ex-husband and my son set up
to run a business that we started which
was a movie theater
and covid hit and killed us
because we still kind of function as a
family
divorced i have
i panicked i sold my house
to take my equity to limp the theater
along
um until all the covenant shutdown
stopped and
my ex-husband did a nice thing and took
over taking care of his
elderly father and bought a home and
went into construction
and made money because he needed to make
money and i had money from
equity to live on and so all this got
strained out
and the goal has always been to let our
son take over this movie theater that
has helped us down
that was closed for 25 years that we had
refurbished and reopened after being
closed for 25 years as a historic
theater
um and i'm sitting here and
i'm hearing more about covert stuff and
the possibility of things
closing again and i was so close dave i
followed all of your sits
and currently i don't have any debt
except for the mortgage on the theater
and i can't get a bank
to figure out how to do a mixed use loan
for 460 000
on a property that is tax assessed at
850
000 i don't know what to do
and i don't want to make the wrong
decision for my son's
future success and i've got
your son's future success is not defined
by this theater
okay your son's future success is
defined by the work ethic and the
character
that you have passed on to him while you
worked on this theater
and the example that you and your ex
have set for your son
that's what his future success is going
to be based on
if ramsay investments ends up worth if
ramsay investments ramsey solutions ends
up worth nothing tomorrow
my kids are going to be just fine
because their future success is not
based on the value of this company
okay so you need to sell this stupid
theater it's a chain around your neck
it's a dream that turned into a
nightmare
that's what i heard did i miss something
no i'm sorry i'm crying
it's okay you you've invested so much
into this
it hurts and when you turn the key on
when you turn the key on a dream that
turns into a nightmare and you walk away
which is what we're doing while we're
talking right here it hurts like crap
your heart breaks
because you you've been heavily invested
in this
um and that just makes you human and it
means you were all in
it means you gave it everything you had
uh hey you didn't you didn't
you didn't invent coveted and you're in
your fault
you got you got screwed by a pandemic
can you sell the stupid thing now
um i had an interested party for
um the tax assessed value take it and
take it take it so the the money that i
would make off of that would
i don't i i don't know what to do with
that money well you have 400 000
in your pocket sounds to me like right
i will yeah if i sell it no and a smile
on your face
and crap in your rear view mirror
i'm literally sitting in my car right
now at the dog park
i lost well i gave up my dog's backyard
because we moved i moved into this
theater yeah
so go get you go get you a life back
this thing took everything from you now
you take it back
well i appreciate that you do what you
want to do if i woke up in your shoes
that's what i would do
i appreciate that i gotta look out for
this town
i think you're a good mom and i think
you gave something your haul
and it's time to cut bait let this one
go
let this one go move on 400 000 gives
you a fresh new start
you're not tied into your ex you and
your son can
you you can make a legacy for him you're
still young you got plenty of things you
can do here
this is the ramsey show
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section
or head to the ramsay show.com thanks
for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us america
open phones this hour as we talk to you
about your life
and about your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two
five five two two five dossier starts us
off this hour in bloomington
illinois hey dasio what's up
hello dave thanks for taking my call can
you hear me sure how can i help
hey um my wife and i are baby steps four
five and six
uh we're expecting our first baby in
about 10 weeks
congratulations thank you very much
um so my question is
we've filed up some money to you know
just in case of an emergency to make
sure that mom and baby come back home
safely
in addition to your emergency fund
correct yes okay about what we have
saved up for emergency fund just in case
something
highly unexpected happens but okay being
conservative
um so when when they do come back home
and
hopefully things will be just fine
my question is should we utilize that
money
and throw it at baby step four and
potentially fully spawn
my girl my baby girl's um
college fund or that'd be baby step five
maybe maybe five's college
okay so just know all of it no no no so
baby step
four is 15 of your income going into
retirement you should already be doing
that
correct we're doing that okay so you
don't need to do anything else with baby
step four baby step
five is save for kids college now how
much money do you have saved for this
baby
this extra emergency fund
about about fifty thousand dollars fifty
thousand dollars
dad dumb okay well you're really safe
that's for sure
um yeah yeah so okay
sit down with your smartvestor pro and
most 529s you're limited to 10k
uh some of them you can do more
depending on which one you choose and
how you choose to do it
uh but sit down with your smartmister
pro and you can probably
fully fund this kid's college yeah out
of this money that's probably what i
would do and just
kind of check that box and go okay what
are we projecting we need when the kid
is 18
18 years from now to go to school and
just based on that let's back into how
much we need to drop into that 529 and
make sure it's the kind of 529
with a smartvestor pro that you choose
the mutual
funds and you put it in the four types
of mutual funds that we talk about
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international
and then whatever you don't use out of
this fifty thousand
for the kids college funding through you
throw it at your mortgage because you're
in baby steps four five and six and
that's how it works
hey thanks for the call mike's in
spokane washington hey mike what's up
nothing much enjoying last what about
you so just the same sir
how can i help all right so
thankfully because of financial peace i
finally i
learned the importance of most got my
parents to finally make one
well my great uncle is also wanting to
do that
and he's wanting to leave me and my kids
everything he has
um but i've seen kind of a lifestyle he
has a 10 has a debt
lifestyle he's okay with having debt um
and i don't have a home me my wife only
make around like
40 000 with me just working her going to
school
how do i sit down with him without
sounding condescending or
like demanding letting him know like hey
i'm glad you want
us to take over everything you have
but um how do i ask like or talk to him
about like
trying to get it so that when he passes
away
i don't get a bunch of debt or like um
having to pay like
um property taxes and stuff
and all this um
without signing condescending because
i'm glad he's leaving it all to us
and i still have to sit down and have
that deep conversation you don't really
need to have that you don't really need
to have that conversation you just do an
audit
when he passes away and you figure out
how much of his stuff you have to sell
to clean up the messy left
and then when you're done you'll have
money
okay so let's say there's some property
taxes due
obviously this prop this stuff is worth
more than he owes on it right
so let's pretend for just a second for
cleanliness sake just for to show you an
example
take a let's say he passed away and you
took everything he owned and you sold it
all
and you paid all the debts that were
against his estate
out of that which you would have to do
okay
you're not liable for the debts but the
estate is liable for the debts
so anything that he owns has to stand
good for anything he owes
before you get an inheritance
do you follow me okay so the yes does
that overrule because what it sounds
like we're talking with him
he has a property and from what the way
he's making it sound
obviously i haven't had this
conversation i just found about about
this yesterday
um but um does that overwhelm if he
puts in his will that it's not to be
sold until my kids are like 18
which is something he's wanting he wants
them to have it
no i'm not going to manage debt for him
after he dies okay
so you could just tell him even if he
would just tell him i don't want it
okay if you're gonna make me manage
something and handle debt
for 20 years after you're gone it's okay
i'll pass
micromanager if you wanna just leave us
this stuff
we'll make sure the kids are taken care
of
okay i mean you're really a micromanager
when you're doing it from the grave
yeah it's a whole new level of yeah uh
yeah
at that point so yeah i mean i so i'm
not gonna take on a bunch of debt
i'm not gonna manage a bunch of debt for
the kids i'm not gonna manage it for you
after you're gone so i'm honored by you
wanting to leave us the stuff and so we
would happy to do this and
happy to uh help um you know happy to
but but you know what we'll require is
that the assets are not
are not frozen in some way um and
we're not required to manage debt
otherwise we won't take it we'll just
turn it down
got it okay perfect so if he wants to
leave it in trust and require that you
manage debt until your children aren't
minors anymore
i don't want to do that i agree with you
on that
that and so you just sit down and just
again you just be very honoring and just
say listen it's not consistent with who
we are
and i appreciate you you're a wonderful
person and thank you for your generosity
but you're asking us to take on
something that we don't believe in for a
period of time
and we're not willing to do that and so
if you want to leave them the stuff
we'll take care of it we'll sell off
enough of it that it becomes debt free
and we'll make sure the kids are blessed
with your
inheritance but if you're going to
require i get in the property management
business and pay your bills after you're
gone
i'll pass so you say it however bluntly
or kindly or gently you want to say it
but you need to deliver the message
because you're right it's all normalized
to him he doesn't think anything about
it he's going to think you're a weirdo
by the way
because you are a wonderful wonderful
weirdo
just like me this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find
healthcare coverage that would meet our
needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
well if you've been paying attention to
the real estate market it's wacky out
there
people making multiple offers putting a
house on the market getting 17 offers in
24 hours and that kind of stuff man it's
crazy in some of these markets
it's intense obviously there's a
shortage of inventory a lot of buyers
looking
not a lot of sellers selling and here we
have a
seller's market for sure this
is not amateur hour if you want to buy a
house right now
you need a pro in your corner to lead
you through this process
if you want to sell a house in this
environment and get the right amount for
it
and don't get all twisted up with some
cookified buyer that's gone nuts in this
current market you need a pro to guide
you through it
now our endorsed local providers have
years of experience on their side
they're high octane high protein
some of the best real estate agents in
the nation
and uh our agents have got years of
doing this
now they don't work for me they're
endorsed by me endorsed local providers
are ramsey trusted
we trust them so go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent and find a ramsey trusted agent
near you
dot ramseysolutions.com slash agent
sadie is with us in lawton oklahoma hi
sadie how are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i'm in oklahoma and recently uh the
oil crashed
and while it was crashed my parents did
what they had
they thought they had to do to get by
got in debt i'm sorry recently the what
crash
say that again the oil field oh yeah
okay okay yeah yeah so your parents did
your parents were working in the oil
field
yeah and um while
it crashed my dad went and got his cdl
and is now driving um
some of my mom are driving campers all
across the united states
but um they're still in debt and they're
just struggling and it's not good for
their health they're older
um they're diabetic my thought my dad
had a heart attack today
he was at the hospital and basically
my brother and i want to sit down and
have a talk with
them that you know stuff doesn't matter
we just want them
here they're gone all the time this job
isn't good for their health how do we
convince them to follow this plan
when they you know that's not how they
live their life
well you can't make adults do anything
unless they're
uh declared mentally incompetent by the
courts
right so my husband and i are following
the plan and basically we just want to
they have to have an income though what
are they going to do when they quit
yeah so my dad is right now 80
disabled through the veterans center um
he has terrible terrible knees needs a
double knee replacement
um could be 100 disabled and then
find something for my mom to do i just
i just you know want to be able to find
a way for them to still
be here to be able to take care of their
health this job is not good for their
health
okay and so so the point is our plan is
about
handling money and um
they have to have money in order to
handle money they have to create an
income that's why they're not afraid of
hard work and doing something
uncomfortable
so what you have is a career crisis in
your mind
that you you want them to stop doing
this and start doing something else and
so
if you want them to not have an income
they're not going to buy that
right so what you need is a suggested
career path
like what would you want your mom and
dad to do if he be
you know if he's sitting around waiting
on disability he's not signing up for
this trip kiddo he's not going to do it
he's not that kind of guy
correct so you know what else can they
do that allows them to come off the road
and be there in lawton oklahoma working
right that's what you need you need a
suggestion
not a complaint i understand you're
scared for them and i understand that
that that they do i don't disagree with
you that they need to come off the road
it sounds like it's really hard on them
um i don't i think you're i think your
conclusion is correct but you're asking
me how to convince them
and your parents are old school when in
doubt
they go to work yeah right
they're not they don't feel entitled
they don't feel like somebody else is
supposed to take care of them
when in doubt they find something to do
and they work and so
if you want them off the road you need a
suggestion where
you something your dad and mom can do
there
that's not the oil field and it's not
driving campers over the road right
and so i don't know what that is um but
you might just sit down and say hey i'm
i love you and i'm concerned about you
what could you guys do if you came home
we'd even be willing to help you and
come around you and so forth and make
sure because we're scared for you and
you know what would be a great job dad
if you landed it back here
right beginning yeah begin to talk it
through with them because if you can
help them create some kind of an income
there and they're they're able to put
their hand to the plow so to speak
that's what's emotionally required for
these folks to
to to come off the road then once you've
got
that then we can talk about putting them
on a ramsay plan
right we can talk about say hey we're
gonna get you on a budget we're gonna
get you out of debt we're gonna teach
you to live on less lesson you make and
you know i i can help you with that part
but right now
um i mean i know these guys are they're
old school right
your dad has worked hard his whole life
yesterday
yeah he's a good man and uh and he he is
not afraid of hard work he's not always
managed the money that he made well
but he's always worked hard and so
that's how he's wired and you have to
find something that's congruent with
that mentality
to suggest quit and come home and sit on
your butt dad
is not going to compute in his brain is
that right
yes sir i mean i i think i know this guy
i think i know who he is and
you know so i mean he he's done a lot of
hard work in his life so
it's okay but and you know he's gonna be
like oh that'd be great how can i buy
food
you know well you can live on your
disability i don't think so honey
so that's the answer you're gonna get so
yeah if you find an
alternative career idea or discuss it
with them and brainstorm and come up
with an alternative career idea
get them home then we can get them into
financial peace university inside
you know this at ramsey plus and you
know get
get them on every dollar and we can have
them manage the money we know what
they've got to work with then
that's very possible good question thank
you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five our question
today comes from a great american
company blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
meaning even if you mismeasure you pick
the wrong color they'll remake your
window blinds for free
you ever seen a company has a you were
stupid guaranteed
[Laughter]
if i'm stupid and i mess this up they
replace it anyway
that's not on them it's on me but they
still replace it this is cool y'all
you get free samples for these guys free
shipping
and the new promos they run all the time
you can save even more money
get your window blinds at blinds.com
always use the promo code
ramsey to get the best possible
deal today's questions from alicia in
florida
i've got 35 thousand dollars in student
loan debt through
sallie mae i only have a part-time job
because my child requires a lot of
medical attention i've tried to
refinance my student loans but i keep
getting denied
i could ask my husband to co-sign for me
should we go that route
if not what should i do um
your husband and you should be managing
your money together
for better for worse in sickness and in
health and by the way that child that
you're taking care of is his too
and so we put all of the household
income in one pile your part-time income
and his income
and we pay off your stinkin student loan
that's what we do this idea that you
have to manage your student loan on a
part-time income because your husband is
off working and you're taking care of
the kid
that he helped create that's bs no we
work together on this
in sickness and health for richer for
poor
unto thee all my worldly goods i
pledge the old fashioned
marriage vows said that
we combine our incomes we combine our
problems
we take care of each other we are a one
unit when we are married
this is not a joint venture it's a
marriage
this is the ramsay chef
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
austin and miranda are with us hey guys
how are you
good good welcome where do you all live
we're from austin texas yeah
austin texas and all the way to
nashville to do a debt-free screen
how much have you paid off 97 000 all
right
how long did that take took us 14 months
and your range of income during that
time it was about 130 to 150.
good what do you guys do for a living
i'm a state trooper
and i'm a school-based speech therapist
awesome
very cool you guys very well done what
kind of debt was your 97
000 student loans all of it
oh wow okay how long you two been
married
three years three years okay so after
you've been married a few months you
look up and you go
we've got a hundred thousand dollars
worth of sallie mae hanging out
yes and we gotta do something about this
tell me the story what happened
so uh it was about two year
we were on the davish plan for about two
years or so
um i actually went through fpu during
the academy
the fpu for government employees so i
went through that
and it kind of gave me a little
understanding about your plan but we
didn't fully fully commit yeah we didn't
commit to it
uh until 14. we we did we were on the
dave ish plan so we did save up and pay
off a car and we were so proud of
ourselves
but we didn't touch the student loans we
were like that's impossible we'll we'll
get to that later
um and then january 2020 we were kind of
at a crossroads
we were like everyone around us was
buying a house or starting their lives
they were like
we want a house we wanted one so bad but
we were kind of like do we buy that or
do
we pay off our student loans and then we
were listening to your show
daily and we're like we can't buy a
house we're broke we don't have any
money
so that's when we decided let's just go
ahead and pay off these student loans
now
just dive in head first and then covet
comes right
of course yeah perfect which made it
easier or harder
easier in that uh couldn't do anything
we couldn't do anything right
yeah no eating out no movies we were
just stuck
stuck at home paying off debt yeah which
is what you were gonna be anyway but
yeah everybody else was stuck at home it
wasn't too bad i guess yeah
yeah so did you guys uh at school you
were getting paid but probably weren't
going in
but you were probably working your tail
off as state trooper right yes yeah yes
very much
yeah and ot and everything else all
kinds of everything
everything i could take yeah yeah yeah
crazy time
crazy time so you knock out a hundred
thousand bucks in just a little over a
year i mean
ninety seven thousand that's impressive
yeah
with the gazelle intensity after that
first you know snowball
the first loan we paid off we were like
whoa we can actually do this
so he was working all the ot he picked
up a second job working overnight shifts
i went in over the summer to do some
contract work
and every extra dollar and we budgeted
as well um
every extra dollar that we could we
threw it towards our student loans
and then at the time when we started
this journey we were living in a
three-bedroom rental
with the yard for our dog all of this
stuff and we realized
we don't need this we can downsize so we
ended up downsizing to a tiny
one-bedroom apartment
um which was half of the rent we were
paying and he ended up
working there too yeah as a security
partner
yeah yeah they give you a rent then yeah
yeah so we got a good discount
and just we threw that extra chunk that
we were paying for our rent at our other
house
towards our loans just every dollar rice
and beans all that stuff yeah all for
just 14 months you could do anything for
14 months
right and you did everything and once we
started
we were like my thought was why did we
start this sooner
we could have started this we could have
done a couple years ago had been done
already
because it we thought it was impossible
but it really was
doable it's all about belief exactly
yeah very impressive you guys very well
done
you got to feel really accomplished we
do it feels
it feels amazing yeah honestly
yes i mean once you i mean just us we're
like
i mean if we did that we can do anything
i mean yeah almost
anything yeah i mean you know because
you just go all right bring it on next
thing
next thing next thing good well done
okay so when somebody says
wow i mean you guys paid off 97 thousand
dollars for 14 months how did you do
that what do you tell them the key is
well obviously budgeting that was the
first step budget
and see where you can cut back see
what's a want versus a need
and then make a plan make your goals the
debt snowball's there for a reason
it works commit you've got to commit
find your why and then just hit it yeah
find some reason to just go all in yeah
you know just go crazy
beast mode you know you just got to go
and that's so
so well done you guys i'm so proud of
you who are your biggest cheerleaders
well definitely each other i mean we
worked together
great i mean we learned a lot about
ourselves too almost daily we'd have to
do the math every week just to keep
motivated like okay
with this much ot because we were
working hard yes
we'd have to check in and be like we can
do this but obviously our families too
understanding when we had to say no and
things like that yeah they were very
understanding about
everything we were doing so so yeah
that's good very good and now you are
free how's it feel
it feels really good amazing yes it's
it's awesome
yeah you ever go back in debt never
never again
never not for a car not for a car not
for anything
all right good good well i'm proud of
you guys
very very very well done inspiring stuff
so now you got to save for a house right
yup yes that's the baby step
uh baby step 3b there you go you're
you're you're game on yeah that's right
good very good you're in a great place
well we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you
because it's the next chapter in your
story you're going to change your whole
legacy with this
and you've just started so really really
good stuff ahead of you
and like you said once you've
accomplished this you know you can do
almost
anything also going to give you an extra
copy of total money makeover to give
away
and get somebody else started on their
journey and pay it forward a little bit
and so all of that guy just for you guys
so
very very well done all right austin and
miranda
from austin texas ninety seven thousand
dollars paid off in 14
months getting it paid 100 and making
130-150 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one
[Applause]
yeah absolutely incredible you guys
so when we did the millionaire study the
ramsey research team
and we studied over 10 000
actual millionaires not your broke
brother-in-law with an opinion
not a twitter troll living in his
mother's basement
but actual millionaires who actually
have
a million dollars or more and we found
out about them you know what was very
interesting
the top five professions
that become a millionaire number three
was teacher
her you know how often they were married
to a policeman
very often very often
so you guys have the perfect career
match at your age
to be future uh baby steps millionaires
you are right on track to do that it
happens
all the time they've got a hundred and
fifty thousand hundred thirty thousand
dollar
household income and by the way only
thirty three percent of the millionaires
that we studied
um no i'm sorry thirty three percent
never made one third of them never made
a household income of over a hundred
thousand
they became millionaires with household
income under a hundred thousand
one-third of them did these guys got a
head start now two-thirds of them did
have over a hundred thousand
but almost none of them made a half a
million dollars a year
almost none of them made four hundred
thousand dollars a year
most of them made 100 to 200 right in
there that's where it fell
right where you guys are sitting so your
case studies
of future baby step millionaires i mean
you fit the mold
almost exactly because uh you know if
you can pay off a hundred thousand
dollars
in 14 months technically speaking
you could have a hundred thousand
dollars in the bank 14 months from today
you see how this is starting to work
tada once you learn how to handle money
and you make it behave instead of you
wonder where it went
and you live in a total freaking chaos
and try to out earn your stupidity once
you stop that stuff
and you go do what austin and miranda
did
yeah you get in financial peace
university go over ramsey plus you get
this stuff going
ding ding boys and girls this is the way
this works
i love it i love it what a sharp young
couple
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today philippians 1 6 god
who began the good work within you
will continue his work until it is
finally finished
albert einstein said a person who never
made a mistake
never tried anything new
[Laughter]
yeah you better be making some mistakes
from time to time folk
that's part of the process here brooke
is with us in las
vegas hi brooke welcome to the ramsay
show
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so i just have a quick question i am a
business owner and i
have i think about two years ago opened
up a roth ira
i've funded it the max each year but
we'd like to start investing my husband
has a separate
401k plan through his company but we'd
like to start investing
more you know up to the 15 if not more
and i'm wondering
once i knocked out both of those three
raw what kind of account to open next we
have a broke risk account
but i am wondering if there's a better
solution as far as tax wise when you go
to pull out the
uh the money okay
you shouldn't i would not be doing
anything in a brokerage account until
you get to 15
how much is in your brokerage account um
i think close to anywhere from i think
50
because we took a hit we're waiting on
money to come back up obviously the
market's down a little bit but um
about 60 percent and actually what
happened was 60 percent you mean 60
000 or 60 000 i'm sorry okay 60 000 yeah
my husband
pulled out of his 401k plan because the
company matches it because
the options that they let him invest in
weren't weren't moving
so when he had the opportunity to
pull out when it was the i think it was
there was that
um i think during code last year
okay um so we just took that money and
rolled it over into another account so
that people will be making money
absolutely horrible idea okay um you
guys have to stop monkeying around with
this stuff all the time
you need to get on a steady plan and be
the tortoise not the hare
so go to go to daveramsey.com click on
smart vester
and find a smartvestor pro in your area
a financial advisor to sit down with
and let's get that money out of a stupid
brokerage account
and um so you see you trashed you lost
your ira
he lost his 401 no no we i we still have
our ira i know he cashed out his 401k
and put it in a brokerage account oh
okay
horrible well not all of it he only took
a portion of it i know but sixty
thousand dollars worth so now we've got
that money just laying there
this is what government pro it was
actually i think it was 45
he pulled out and we we've made money on
okay
that's wonderful still a stupid idea
okay
anyway now to answer your question
what's your household income
uh about 130 000. okay
so 15 of that
is uh going to be what uh eighteen
thousand bucks
okay right and so eighteen thousand
dollars that's fifteen hundred dollars a
month
needs to be going into something in good
growth stock mutual funds
the best place to put it is where there
is a match
does his 401k have a match
right they do they match him dollar per
dollar up to six percent i think
so he's already been doing that so we're
going to do
at least six percent first
and what and what is his income times
six percent
up to towards our towards our 18 000 for
the year
okay the next best thing is a roth does
his 401k
have a roth option um i don't believe so
but i opened up no no no no no no
stay with me stay with me here okay
let's stick with his 401k
roth okay option all right now
um if it has a roth option and it
probably does
that's what he needs to be in then you
look at his
selection of mutual funds and you pick
the best ones and your smart mr pro can
help you look at what his options are
inside there and you stink and leave
those alone
once you pick them right because this is
all growing
tax free with a match no brokerage
account the freaking world is going to
keep up with that
even if the mutual funds are
underperforming they're going to be
better
at tax-free growth than what you were
what this crap you've been doing with
your own your own over here with this
brokerage account
monkeying around with us has lost you
all so much money then
we're gonna do two roth iras
up to six thousand dollars that's twelve
thousand dollars
see we're easily going to get to our
eighteen thousand dollars with this
gotcha okay okay so the eighteen 000 is
what we're
after per year going in so we're gonna
take the match at six percent
we're gonna do your two roth in good
mutual funds
and then we're gonna do more in his 401k
hopefully roth in not so good mutual
funds
because it sounds like his options
aren't that great okay
yeah and um that's going to get us up to
the 18 18 000 a year which is
15 percent of your 130 thousand and
that's what you're going to do
you're again your smartvestor pro can
help you lay all of that out and get all
of that rolling
and of course if you have any debt we're
going to use that brokerage account to
clear that
if you don't have an emergency fund
we're going to use a brokerage account
to create
a three to six month expenses emergency
fund
we're going to create a situation where
all of those things are covered all of
the baby steps all the way through
and that is what we're going to do
brooke and then you're going to be on a
steady
steady plan thanks for the call
okay guys let's step back up the people
that end up in the millionaire study
being millionaires
are the ones that steadily invest
here's what the irony is a lot of the
millionaires that we studied
were not expert investors who
maximized rates of returns
many times they had medium to poor
decent mutual funds that they were
investing in
almost the majority of them could have
done
better with their mutual funds
selections
and yet they still became millionaires
and the so the association of actuaries
did a study
which is like super nerds okay this says
that
74 of the reason
that someone becomes wealthy
is savings rate now it's not the rate
that they make on their savings
it's what it's that they constantly save
a set percentage a good percentage of
their income
like fifteen percent of your income and
baby step four towards
their investments
so here's the point seventy four percent
of the people who
who become wealthy that's almost all of
them
that's statistically significant do so
not because of commissions or no
commissions on their mutual funds
not because of their expense ratios on
their mutual funds so not even because
of the rates of return on their mutual
funds
it's because they keep doing it over and
over and over and over again
and no one can talk them out of it
savings
rate meaning they actually
freaking invest the secret to wealth
is to invest invest invest
don't stop investing invest
invest invest don't stop
investing that's the secret
now i would like for you to and i would
like to
pay less expenses on my investments i
would like for you to and i would like
to
make a pick better mutual funds and get
better rates of return
and those are all good things but they
are not the secret sauce
74 percent of the reason that people
become wealthy is they
actually invest and they invest
and they invest and they invest
and they invest and they invest and they
invest and then best
that's simple guys it's that simple
and so uh you have got to be steady with
this
jumping in and out trying to catch the
market trying to find the edge
trying to find some kind of secrets of
the rich is so much
bs and it does not work getting
frustrated because your stuff's not
doing what it's supposed to do and you
move it all around all the time
you're constantly monkeying with this is
not the answer
constantly steadily invest
invest invest invest
and that's how you get there
[Music]
this is the ramsey show we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcast
[Music]
you